[Music]
fighting in order to live
[Music]
and living to fight
that's the way of our world
[Music]
ionios
tell me
what would possess you to side with them
we're fighting because there are enemies
to kill i refuse to believe you're him
i knew it i saw this coming you are
you're not enemies now fine for you
isn't it all that time you've got you
could try
try to move forwards again how can our
lives be so snuffing little do you
they're not your friends anymore they're
his few
sword match
the land pierced by a great sword
it's the only way you're gonna defeat
the real enemy
whatever life is lost i won't let you
soldier all alone what could filling up
these flickering clocks in our eyes it
will never replace the predatory block
the blame clock it has to go
uroboros are bore this world they must
be erased without a trace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
the cycle of this world i will not allow
it to perish with you
[Music]
i seek to destroy the irrational power
structure that shackles fodman
if the kingdom is ever to part ways with
our bloody past
this is the path we must walk
i have ambitions edelgard real ones
[Music]
will you sit around and wait for a
miracle
or will you help me seize control of my
fate
we shall fight
we shall survive and we shall win a
glorious future for foodland
but now that i know
i won't make the same mistake again
[Applause]
revenge is not a thing you take for
someone else
[Music]
you seek revenge to slake your rage and
heal your wounded heart
i know you are prepared to do whatever
that you must
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mario striker's battle league
prepare for strife a five-on-five sport
like soccer that's way heavy on offense
aim for goals by dribbling and passing
to teammates as well as by using tackles
items
and crushing special shots
the main rule in this sport is to rule
the field
try to score more goals than your
opponents
there are two things to keep in mind
that'll help you with your strategies
first the gear you equip it changes not
only your appearance but also your stats
like speed strength and pass accuracy
customize as you see fit
second
the hyper strike
to activate this shot grab an orb when
it appears on the field
and charge it while your opponents are
distracted
hit the net and you'll score not one but
two goals
up to eight players four players on each
team can compete against each other on
one nintendo switch system
in addition to individual matches online
play will have an online club mode
join an in-game club and compete for
placement in the rankings
up to 20 players can join a club so
create your own and invite friends and
family to play alongside you or join an
existing one owned by other players
try to become the world's tough club
with items
tackles
and hyper strikes
anything goes on this field
mario strikers battle league launches on
nintendo switch june 10th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
it's a new iteration of the wii sports
series
nintendo switch sports
let's begin with these three sports you
might recognize them from past wii
sports games
[Music]
tennis
rally by gently swinging the joy-con
controller at the right time
bowling roll the ball straight ahead or
give it a little curve
[Music]
and chambra
knock your opponent off the platform
while attacking and defending
plus three additional sports are joining
the lineup
[Music]
soccer
use a gigantic ball to make dynamic
plays
enjoy matches with joy-con controllers
to shoot and perform diving headers
by attaching a joy-con controller to the
leg strap accessory included with the
physical version of the game you can
play shootout mode with intuitive
kicking motion
badminton
control your shots left and right while
keeping the shuttlecock in the air
unleash powerful smash shots to gain the
upper hand
[Music]
finally volleyball
use a joy-con controller to serve
bump
set
and spike the ball
[Music]
the game supports local play with family
and friends on one nintendo switch
system as well as online play across all
sports
play against friends online
or
opt for random matchmaking the more you
win the tougher the players you'll face
try taking on this challenge
[Music]
the nintendo switch sports game launches
april 29th
a free update is scheduled for this
summer that lets you play soccer matches
with the joy-con controller and the leg
strap accessory you can use the
accessory to play shootout mode at
launch
in addition
a second free update that lets you enjoy
golf
will launch this fall
plus an online play test is planned
before launch to evaluate various
technical aspects
it will only be available for players
with an active nintendo switch online
membership for the date shown on screen
if you're interested please visit the
official nintendo website for more
details
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
paid dlc courses will be coming to the
mario kart 8 deluxe game
this is the mario kart 8 deluxe booster
course pass
you may recognize some courses from past
mario kart games
eight courses will be released at a time
over six waves that's 48 additional
courses we plan on releasing by the end
of 2023
courses such as coconut mall
choco mountain
[Music]
and tokyo blur will be included in the
first wave
of course you can play these courses
locally and online
[Music]
the first wave of the mario kart 8
deluxe booster course pass will launch
march 18th
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
it's kirby's latest unforgettable 3d
platforming adventure kirby and the
forgotten land
it all takes place in a mysterious world
with an unusual mix of nature and
civilization
to rescue the kidnapped waddle dees
kirby sets off on a new adventure
[Applause]
introducing
mouthful mode
inhale a car to zoom around
[Music]
a vending machine to attack with juice
cans
or become a piercing cone
with mouthful mode new actions will be
available for kirby depending on the
object he inhales
[Applause]
enjoy exploring with new moves different
from copy abilities
kirby can even weaponize a mouthful of
water like this
as kirby rescues waddle dees waddle
d-town will continue to grow and more
resources will become available
at waddle dee's weapon shop familiar
copy abilities can be evolved
[Music]
evolve copy abilities to expand kirby's
range of attacks
they'll also change kirby's appearance
and make him even more powerful
[Music]
some copy abilities may have stronger
involved forms
[Music]
a new adventure awaits our pink puffball
who are the beasts back
what are these enemies trying to do
can kirby restore peace to this world
kirby and the forgotten land launches on
the nintendo switch system march 25th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
[Music]
so
[Music]
did you
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
ready
[Music]
we've got more intel on the advance wars
oneplus 2 reap boot camp game in the
first campaign advance wars you'll
advise a colorful cast of commanding
officers and use their abilities in
vibrant turn-based battles each
commanding officer is now voiced
bringing even more charm to these
characters you're gonna get hurt i see
right through your plans another full
campaign awaits in advance wars 2 black
hole rising more commanding officers and
more diverse terrain can be leveraged
for additional tactical opportunities
like blasting through pipelines to cross
into enemy territory in both campaigns
you can fast forward gameplay and reset
your turns for a smoother tactical
experience
flex your strategic muscles outside of
both campaigns with additional modes go
for high scores in the war room
create and share custom maps in the
design room
or battle friends and frenemies in local
and online multiplayer
[Music]
advance wars oneplus 2 reboot camp
marches onto the nintendo switch system
april 8th pre-orders are available now
on nintendo esha
two worlds cross in the triumphant
return of this rpg classic
a remaster of the acclaimed rpg chrono
cross is coming to the nintendo switch
system
one fateful day the protagonist surge
wanders into an alternate world though
it somewhat resembles his homeworld he
finds that he no longer exists here
how did this happen
what is this mysterious another world
travel back and forth between both
worlds to unravel the story over 40
characters can join your party
depending on the choices you make the
allies who accompany you and the endings
that trigger will differ
a number of improvements have been made
to this remaster
like the ability to turn off enemy
encounters
and a newly enhanced soundtrack
plus radical dreamers originally
released on the satella view is included
experience the origins of chrono cross
in this text-based adventure
chrono cross the radical dreamers
edition dashes and slashes its way onto
nintendo switch april 7th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
clinoa is coming to nintendo switch
across dreamy side scrolling levels
you'll run jump and hover while firing
wind bullets to grab and throw enemies
use each level surroundings to your
advantage
[Music]
also clinoa 2 is included
take on these great adventures when
clinoa fantasy reverie series launches a
nintendo switch july 8th
oh
it's you
it's been a long time
how have you been
the dual portal device should be around
here somewhere once you find it we can
start testing
just like old times
sorry about the mess
i've really let the place go since you
killed me
by the way thanks for that
the important thing is you're back
with me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
earthbound and earthbound beginnings
will be added to nintendo switch online
shortly after this presentation
you